I want to provide you some hints as to
how to go about restructuring this code.
You have already seen all the code
necessary to complete this challenge.
All of the CRUD operations from
lesson one will come in handy here.
You will have to import the modules
you used to do your CRUD commands in
lesson one.
Alll of the code for
these objectives can be written
within your web server.pi file.
You'll need to reconstruct your do_GET
and do_POST methods, such that they
perform the necessary CRUD operations
to create the desired functionality.
Print statements are simple ways to
see if our code is flowing the way
we expect.
Feel free to use print statements to
see what blocks your code is in, and
the value of variables,
like I did with the output variable
that showed our HTML code.
Within your browser, you can view source
code, as well as inspect DOM elements,
to see if you are outputting the HTML
you expect to see from your server code.